Russians seem to be very good at taking
something and bringing it to a whole new
level take ballet for example it was
invented in Italy popularized in France
but the ballet we know now would not be
here if it weren't for the Russians and
the heart of ballet here in st.
Petersburg is right here at the marine
scheme the father of ballet in Russia
was Marius Petipa the legendary
choreographer who gave us such timeless
classics as Sleeping Beauty and Swan
Lake but the first thing he did in
Russia was Paquita which he staged in
this theater in 1847 today were
fortunate to witness something very
special
Paquita reimagined for the 21st century
by company dancer URIs McAuliffe
would is ballet for Russian people nuez
mothership it's stylish
rosco each layer can des bolita at the
plaster quilt or Kotori Deanna's if les
tradition Varnum e mu jvo my team
edition is important most
says machine e musically form a
sonography disc a former dancer only for
my at Navis recent as much gusto it's
all made to look effortless but I can
assure you the precision strength
balance and endurance of these
ballerinas rivals any professional
athlete they rehearse up to six hours a
day
it can take 40 minutes for them just to
put their pointe shoes on and all this
just to give us a chance to escape from
reality into a fairy tale it's all
happening a few moments from now Paquita
reimagined the orchestra is warming up
and so are the dancers you can feel the
tension in the air but ultimately
they're not worried the future of ballet
is safe and the Marine sting
you
[Music]